clock is ticking and that means there
are fewer and fewer hours to go
shopping if you are still searching for
ideas anthony johnson
has some of the season's must have gifts
the holiday shopping clock is ticking
but it's no reason to fret
we want convenient seamless experiences
when we're out shopping
during the holiday season we have enough
to worry about right so that's why i
love the fact that dix offers
contactless curbside pickup where i can
order everything that i want online
and then within an hour show up at the
store and they actually bring
everything to your car if you're still
not quite sure what to grab the people
on your list here's some advice
it's definitely not too late to give the
gift of sport if you have like a lot of
stress in your shoulders or you have an
athlete who likes those personal
massagers
check out the hyper ice hypervolt
percussion massager it is the
must-have gift for the golfer on your
list top flight golf balls are perfect
last minute gift or maybe even something
for a stocking stuffer
and if you still can't figure out what
you want to give
a loved one get them a gift card that
way they can go shopping and get what
they want this holiday season
place your order at dix.com and consider
one-stop shopping
to minimize the stress